I saw you on the afri 30 rows right
there was five of us that got to me here
so I can tell the guys in the house are
jealous I mean who wouldn't want to be
one of the first guys to meet her you
have such a calming presence okay it's a
huge advantage you just get another time
to have a first impression to see you
again got to remember me how would you
rate the other guys the cam guy crush it
the one who came on rapt
how about cam getting a rose already
he's probably coming tonight like he's
super Elliot I know nerves I would love
to know what he's gonna do when he gets
here
yeah Oh mr. rose showing it off it's
definitely a great feeling knowing that
I'm pretty much guaranteed more time
with her what did you do today
I did another freestyle you know was
spitting some bars like Willy Wonka so
no big deal
but I've got to keep the momentum going
because there's other gentlemen in there
that are trying to go for the same woman
that I'm going for
how did you get so good at freestyle
Ravi I'm just a B C always be cam I'm
not here for my 15 minutes of fame I'm
here for my lifetime of love and I'm
gonna show her that I'm here for the
long haul
[Music]